a new flaw has been found on Boeing 737
max Jets and it's expected to further
delay the plane's return to service the
737 max leet you'll recall was grounded
worldwide in March after two deadly
crashes overseas Kris Van Cleave is at
Reagan National Airport outside
Washington Chris it sounds like a
another setback for Boeing what's behind
it well good morning FAS pilots have
been going through all of the changes to
the 737 max in a flight simulator in
Seattle and it was during that testing
that they discovered this new issue
which they believe to be a pre-existing
problem with the airplane during what
was described as a failure scenario
where the nose of the plane was being
pushed down similar to what happened in
both max crashes they discovered a
microprocessor in the flight control
computer can become overloaded that
slowed down the test pilots ability to
respond to that nose down situation
essentially allowing it to continue
longer than they felt it should the FAA
is concerned here is if this scenario
presented itself during an actual flight
it could increase the chances of a crash
Boeing believes an additional software
update can address this newly-discovered
issue if it doesn't the company may have
to replace the component on all of the
grounded max planes yesterday Boeing CEO
Dennis Muhlenberg said by the time the
737 max is updated and certified it will
be one of the safest airplanes to ever
fly the FAA says it will not conduct the
airborne flight tests necessary to
approve the changes to the max until
this issue is resolved yesterday United
Airlines joined American and Southwest
in pulling the max off its flight
schedule until at least September 3rd
Anthony Kris Van Cleave with more
problems for the 737 max thanks Chris